[Music]
all right I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Rubin report it's October 10th 2023 we
are live streaming on Rumble locals and
YouTube as always who knows how long we
will uh remain on YouTube as obviously
we're going to be talking about some uh
some depressing stuff at times showing
you some uh horrific stuff at times and
everything else so if you do have a
moment if you could just jump over to
rumble.com
rubben report and subscriber or join us
in the locals Community uh it'll be the
best way that I can stay in touch with
you guys you know uh amidst all of the
problems that we have now we still have
a massive big big Tech problem and as it
gets more difficult to talk about these
controversial topics and and just the
horrors that are happening all over the
world and I suspect unfortunately we're
just at the beginning of them uh the
best way to get me if you want to stay
in touch with me because Twitter could
be taken out tomorrow it's still running
on Amazon AWS elon's got a lot to work
with there uh join us over over on uh on
locals and you don't even have to pay
it's just if you want to just join us
it's great if you support anyway none of
that really matters relative to what's
going on in the world I'm sorry we were
about late a minute late today uh this
morning I went Governor Dan santis came
down to Miami and went to a a temple in
Surf Side uh and I was invited and a few
other people and he gave just a really
uh fantastic speech I I took that
picture um he just gave a great speech
about moral Clarity and the difference
between western civilization and
barbarism and the right to respond and
just and it was just good and then of
course talked about how uh Florida will
not put up and put up with any of this
if you threaten our citizens or if you
are breaking the laws or just like any
of that stuff it was just No Nonsense no
BS any of that uh so I'm just so
freaking proud to live in this state
which I now consider the other Promised
Land let's say uh before we get into
today's stuff and obviously it's mostly
going to be about what's going on in the
world and then I want to do one little
sort of um American political thing up
top involving RFK because I think it's a
seminal moment related to the Democrats
which has led to so much of this
Insanity throughout the world right now
with our Democrat Party and our left and
our liberals losing their minds it it
actually turned into a big problem for
everybody but before I do that real
quick um you know I I just want to thank
everybody who watched yesterday I I
think I probably read every single uh
well I always read all the the locals
comments uh but I think I read every
single YouTube comment yesterday I think
I read every single Rumble comment
yesterday uh this morning at the temple
people coming up to me and talking about
the show we did yesterday um it was
obviously not easy for me I I meant what
I said yesterday and that I did not know
what I was going to do and I felt sort
of like I got hit by a truck for the
rest of the day um it was uh you
know I'm honestly I'm not that emotional
I'm actually not that emotional I can
kind of do my silly stuff in this room
but like I I don't I don't tear up that
often I don't cry that often you know
when I toured with Jordan and people
would tell him all of these just insane
stories about their life and what they
had gone through and Horrors and and the
Vindication and the comeback and all
those things and Jordan Jordan could be
brought to tears like that and I was
always sort of like I was kind of like
Amazed by it at times and then also like
like is there something wrong with me
that I can't do that um but I did have
one of those moments uh in in my bedroom
after the show yesterday um but I feel
renewed and ready to continue fighting
this thing and it's a as I said it ain't
going anywhere and and don't think that
this is just a problem with the Middle
East because as we're going to lay out
today that we now have a problem on all
of our Western Shores and everything
else so anyway I just I just appreciate
your support and I'm going to just keep
trying to do the best that I can do and
we're all in it together for as long as
uh we have this precious free country uh
okay so uh I want to start today
actually by talking about RFK Jr and you
might think that that's a little bit off
the beaten path of where the world is at
at the moment but he did leave the
Democrat Party he officially announced
that yesterday we kind of knew was
coming as some of you guys remember when
he announced way back when what was that
maybe 6 months ago at this point I said
that day he will be a republican by the
end of this thing now he has he is
saying he's an independent not a
republican but in essence my point was
he when he finds out how evil and
corrupt and rotted out the Democrat
Party is and the base of that party he
as an old school liberal who I have
disagreements with he will get out of
that party and I think he probably
really is just sort of a moderate
Republican at this point well he has
left and I want to link why he left the
radicalism of his party when it came to
borders you think that's important right
now that was a big one that has woken
him up over the last couple months uh
when it came to this gender nonsense
when it came to free speech all of the
things that I'm constantly talking about
on the show that you guys all know are
the are the most important things for a
free Society right have a border be able
to say what you want uh clearly and and
and cleanly without the threat of the
government coming after you or big Tech
quashing you uh and now where we are at
as we are watching uh the world
basically upside down we are watching
the progressive left and this doesn't
surprise me but I think some people are
actually they're a little behind the
curve on this stuff we are watching the
progressive left and the Hamas caucus
like AOC and ilhan Omar and Rashida toib
and these other I would I would say
basically uh they are Hamas supporters
that we have in our in our government um
as we watch them defend and they are
defend I'm going to show you some things
on today's show and we're going to talk
about some things that are again words
are not you can't they are not words I
can say words but it doesn't describe it
we're going to show you some images but
as they defend bar barbaric medieval
acts that are unimaginable second level
Holocaust type stuff it's kind of here
and a whole bunch of us were saying hey
we better deal with that radical lunacy
that's detached from reality that is
silencing people that is shutting people
out that is allowing anyone in and their
brother to come into this country and do
whatever they want these things are all
deeply connected so that's what we're
doing today uh let me talk to you guys
about tax Network USA real quick uh you
guys know that the IRS October 15th tax
deadline is right around the corner time
does fly uh if you're scrambling think
about those estimated payments expense
write-offs and messy deductions well
I've got a recommendation for you the
attorneys at tax networks USA have been
absolute Lifesavers for many their team
successfully saved clients over a
billion in tax debts whether you're in
the hole for10 ,000 are staring at 10
million in debt hey that could be Hunter
Biden uh they're ready to help and hey
no judgment here even if you haven't
filed in one F or a Whole Decade they're
equipped to secure your best settlement
for you I'd say that's quite a tax
Lifeline so before the tax clock Runs
Out give tax Network USA a shout and now
back to me okay so you will see how I
link Robert F Kennedy officially a
Kennedy right like the the name the sort
of standard bearer of americ
Democrat Party uh one of the last ones
in public life left Robert F Kennedy Jr
officially leaving the Democrat party
yesterday and announcing that he will
run for president as an independent and
they remind me that this country is
ready for a history-making change are
ready they are ready to reclaim their
freedom their
independence
and I know I saw that and I thought
that and that's why I'm here today I'm
here to declare myself an independent
candidate all right so I want to be
clear it doesn't matter if you would
ever consider running uh supporting cedy
or not it really doesn't matter right
like most of you probably not going to
vote for a recent Democrat even if you
like him on especially on the coid stuff
and now you like him on the border stuff
but the point is he is run because he
has now fully realized that the modern
Democrat Party which by the way is also
fixing the primary against him right we
know this we've gone over it a couple
times that if he was even to step foot
in those early primary States like Iowa
the votes were going to go all the way
to Biden because they said if a
candidate steps into the state it goes
to the incumbent because they're fixing
the primary for the elderly man
pretending to be president he has
realized the party is too radical and
that really is what the theme of today's
show is uh Jordan Peterson saw that
video and commented and he wrote this on
Twitter Twitter now Robert Kennedy Jr
has come to understand some of the depth
the rot in the Democrats Jordan has been
writing a lot of his tweets like hauz
lately I'm not exactly sure why but I
kind of dig it um so okay so he is
leaving so what would the reaction be if
he is leaving Well Carrie Kennedy krie
Kennedy is his sister if I'm not
mistaken right uh she tweeted out this
Bobby might share the same name as our
father yeah the sister but does not
share the same values Vision or judgment
today's announcement is deeply saddening
for us we denounce his candidacy and
believe it to be perilous for our
country that is RFK Jr's sister when
clearly RFK has far more to do with JFK
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
getting us out of Wars uh fighting the
Deep State and all of those things he
has far more uh to do with his dad than
whatever she purports to think the de
the Democrats now believe in uh one more
from Jordan here uh he saw that and he
responded and said the Kennedy family is
as broken as the Democrats um yeah yeah
they they are broken the other kennedies
they are by the way I'll be doing an
event with RFK Jr he knows that I'm
obviously supporting disantis but I'll
always give him a fair Shake I'm doing
an event with him in Los Angeles on on
uh October 26th which we'll put on the
the we'll put on YouTube and Rumble and
everything else sorry I'm a little
scattered today guys um so why why am I
bringing all this up because the
radicalization of the Democrat Party has
now seeped through every part of society
and that links us to what's going on
here now what I would say is the
outright support by ilhan Omar AOC and
the rest of the Hamas caucus they have
lost their minds now so far Joe Biden's
been pretty decent on this but he also
released $6 billion to Iran Donald Trump
and Ronda santis by the way and many
many others warned him hey if you give
the Mulla six billion what do you think
they're going to do we played a clip on
this show a couple weeks ago where one
of the I think it was the Iranian
president was basically like yeah they
said we can't use it for weapons but you
know we're going to do whatever's good
for the Iranians which every country
does for itself so now I will link that
to everything else let me talk to you
about my Patriot Supply real quick uh do
you guys get the feeling that something
Unthinkable is going to happen soon
Jesus Christ a little too on the money
guys uh well many do and with all the
distractions and smok screens in the
media we probably won't see it coming
that's why it's smart to invest in
emergency food today A wise man once
said it's better to have it uh and not
need it than to not have it and need it
my Patriot Supply is the nation's leader
in emergency food storage go to my
website prepare with ruben.com and
you'll save 25% on my Patriot supplies
three months em three-month emergency
food kit you'll enjoy a wide variety of
delicious meals providing over 2,000
calories a day for Optimum strength
under stress stock up now before
everyone else panics free shipping is
automatic and your order ships fast go
to prepare withth ruben.com prepare
withth ruben.com and now back to me so I
have mentioned the phrase the Hamas
caucus a couple times uh I think I came
up with that a couple years ago but
maybe I'm not the first one to ever say
it but I want to show you this tweet
that I put up yesterday can we get that
one up uh this is I I retweeted I didn't
know who this account was Chicago of Ray
they wrote the media made sure everyone
knew who the eight Republicans were that
sided with Gates so it's up to us to let
everyone know who the eight leftist
Democrats are that sided with Hamas
today and then of course you've got AOC
and Omar and Presley and TB and Bowman
and Bush and Caesar and Lee these people
are dullards they are anti-American they
swore an oath uh to protect the
Constitution of the United States I have
no doubt that they would gladly shred
that document if they could they have
shown far more sympathy with a foreign
terrorist organization which I think
would actually be a violation of their
oath of office I Al I also think it's a
violation of any congressman's oath of
office when you have an open border it's
their duty to protect the borders of
this country and we better damn well get
serious about some of this stuff uh
because more and more we have no idea
how many people are in our country right
now and where they are and what they're
doing well in Florida we've probably a
better sense of things um but we just
simply do not know I want to show you
one other thing from Jordan because he
retweeted that and he he wrote something
interesting and it connects us to the
RFK point he wrote I asked dozens of
Democrats over the last few years
congressmen and Senators alike in behind
the scenes talks when does the left go
too far not a single one answered
including Robert Kennedy Jr not one now
they're finding out and it's a little
late now I suspect that Robert Kennedy
Jr now knows when the left goes too far
right we've seen it with him he now
knows what's going on at the border uh
in my conversation with him that you
might have seen from a few months ago
when I when I really pushed him on the
Supreme Court decision related to
affirmative action he basically came
around to my position on that uh but
this was a discussion that Jordan and I
had been having for years when we were
on tour and we and it was far bigger
than me and Jordan we'd have we'd have
incredible intellectuals with us and
politicians and all these people there
was always this conversation this
non-stop conversation happening could
the Democrat Party be reformed we all
saw right you guys certainly saw it some
of you are are new I suppose to this
show and waking up to some of this stuff
but for years now there were a whole
bunch of us talking about how radical
left had gone how Up Is Down with them
and left is right and boys are girls and
all of the stuff bad guys are good guys
they can excuse any violence if it's in
the name of their ideology all of the
stuff and I always was saying um that
the Democrat Party is done there is
nothing left we have to move on and and
we have to build new alliances and
clearly my life is an example of how you
do that on the right I Me by no means a
traditional conservative and I don't
really consider myself a republican
other than I'm a Florida Republican for
sure uh but this was a debate that
Jordan had for a long time and Jordan
would always say to me uh that he would
keep working with the Democrats as long
as he could now he's even saying yeah I
tried it did not work it simply did not
work so why didn't it work well let's
see the Democrats stance on Israel now
remember there are over 1300 uh Israelis
dead it's probably far more burned alive
raped in front of uh dead women raped in
front of dead husbands there's some un
like really unspeakable stuff we'll get
to in a second I mean it's it's you got
the point so ilhan Omar who is a Somali
immigrant first generation immigrant
into the United States uh who has become
powerful and influential here in this
country and a congresswoman uh and I
believe her to be actually an enemy of
the United States of America and the
people of Minnesota I suppose will have
to decide if they want to reelect or her
not uh here she is finally chiming in on
what's going on in Gaza reminder Gaza
doesn't have shelters or an Iron Dome
and to please pray for them may peace
peace Prevail in the region and move us
towards a moral Awakening to care about
human suffering we are seeing
Palestinians are human beings who have
been besieged and are deserving of
protection from the International
Community well Palestinians are besieged
she's right by Hamas there's not one
Israeli that lives in Gaza they
completely moved every Israeli out there
were about 8,000 Jews living there
Hitler would love the place there's not
one Jew right like that's what Hitler
wanted right Jude and Ryan there's none
there they left they said we want
nothing to do with you they left green
houses they left infrastructure Hamas
took over they killed their opposition
and for all of these years all of the
billions and billions of dollars that
Hamas got and what did they build they
clearly built an an incredibly effective
Guerilla Army instead of building say
bomb shelters or an Iron Dome or
anything else she's just a
communist I don't know how to say
it any other way sorry if you're
watching with the kids what you know
what am I going to do I have to tell you
what I think um we got another one uh
this is from end wokeness Rashida Talib
who's also in the Hamas caucus uh she
has this is great representative
representative Rashida Talib is flying a
Palestinian flag and an lgbtq pride flag
outside of her office who wants to tell
her yeah you know the thing is with the
they them crowd if you go to Gaza first
they behead they and then they behead
them that's how it works over there but
again this shows the radicalism of the
Democrat Party these ideologies have
nothing to do with each other right you
think for so think about it they put the
Palestinian cause at the height of their
thing right like it's just it's the Jews
are bad somehow the Jews had nothing to
do with Israel and the history of the
Bible and thousands of years of
archaeological reality and historical
reality and everything else but the Jews
are really bad and they're oppressing
these people and then somehow they've
combined that with the
lgbtq2 spirit element op Fiasco right
she knows like go lady take grab a
couple lesbos and go to Gaza and see
what happens see what happens but she
will not but the hypocrisy of these
people uh never end but let's uh let's
continue um Step Miller uh who's who
strikes me as an actual like journalist
type human being I can say that without
air quotes that's nice uh he tweeted
this out just a reminder the Twitter
account of AOC with 13 million followers
has gone completely dark over the rape
kidnapping and summary executions of
innocent residents in Israel over the
past 2 days uh eventually did release a
statement I don't know that she put it
on her Twitter but it was a very
prepackaged statement and she called
immediately for a ceasefire so it's like
yeah we're going to rape all your women
and we're going to kill all your kids
and barbaric Butchery literally taking
Holocaust Survivors I mean that image I
think we showed it to you yesterday of
that roughly 80-year-old woman in a
wheelchair she survived a schwitz and
now she is in Gaza somewhere alive Dead
who knows who knows uh but this is this
is the Democrat Party uh here's Gretchen
Whitmer now you know Gretchen Whitmer is
the overly boto psychopath who is
running uh Michigan right now who got
reelected by the people of Michigan uh
she was partying during coid while she
was locking people down she didn't want
people to have uh to be able to grow
their own fruits and vegetables during
Co I mean she's an authoritarian lunatic
which would probably explain why she
likes M uh this is listen to this mey
mouthed amoral nothing statement that
she put up there I have been in touch
with communities impacted by what's
happening in the region it is abhorent
my heart is with all those impacted we
need peace in the region what a pathetic
indifferent you know all that evil needs
to flourish is for good people to do
nothing right who who said that I think
it was Hanah orent maybe um like we're
there we're there we're there good
people will do nothing yes if you bury
your head in the sand it they're just
going to behead you a little bit higher
up on the neck that's how it works uh
Barack
Obama uh did not tweet for about 48
hours did not say a word about it now
many people think Obama and the Obama
Administration are running the show in
the White House CU it's obviously not
Biden and by the way you know as
critical as I am on Biden I will say
this Biden I don't think hates Israel I
don't think Biden hates Jews by any
measure whatsoever I think Obama does
and I think that's fairly obvious Obama
Obama it took him 48 hours but he did
finally he chat gped this thing to get
all the buzzwords in there can we get
the Obama statement we can skip that one
we can skip his last one it doesn't
matter we have the Obama statement
yeah uh all Americans should be
horrified and outraged by the Brazen
terrorist attacks on Israel and the
slaughter of innocent civilians we
grieve for those who died pray for the
safe return of those who've been held in
who've been held hostage and stand
squarely alongside our Ally Israel as it
dismantles Hamas as we support Israel's
right to defend itself we must keep
striving for a just and Lasting peace
for Israelis and Palestinians like so
actually it's not terrible the last
statement is just is just the
nothingness that they offer up after
afterwards uh but this is pretty uh part
and parcel uh with what Obama has done
with almost everything right at a little
of everything but by the way when I say
he didn't tweet this is why we had a
little pause there before we showed you
that tweet when I tell you that he
didn't tweet for 48 hours uh it's not
that he didn't tweet for 48 hours he did
tweet once uh after the attacks had
happened he tweeted this for decades
narges Mohamed has been a vocal advocate
for women and girls in Iran this Nobel
Prize is a well-deserved recognition of
her courage and the hope that she
represents not only for the women of
Iran but for women fighting repression
and violence around the world I have no
doubt she's probably pretty good the
woman probably deserve some uh you know
some praise or something right that's
nice and and I'm and I stand for all the
women who are fighting against
oppression in Iran and want freedom and
all of the other minorities and
everything else uh but as we have
watched what I now think is not an
exaggeration to say is the new Holocaust
right it's not 6 million people but it
is it is to Reign ter Terror on a nation
of about 8 million people with the with
the Holocaust level most unimaginable
hars that you could possibly think of
took him 48 hours to put that thing
together and and it felt like he read it
from chat GPT let let me give you more a
little more information so again what
I'm doing here is laying out how
ridiculous and and narrative driven and
propagandic propagandistic uh the
Democrat Party has become right they're
all coming off as neutral or equalizing
or indifferent or whatever else and it's
like what I just just for anyone
watching this what would you
do what would you do if they murdered
your family and kidnapped your grandma
and beheaded your child but what would
be the moral thing to do uh we're
planning a couple shows where I'm going
to try to get away from the politics all
this and talk about the moral response
to an atrocity I want to talk about it
from a Biblical perspective so I'm going
to try to get a Jewish biblical scholar
on the Old Testament I want to get
somebody Christian scholar on the on the
uh New Testament I want to get a secular
ethicist because I don't want this with
the you're going to be able to watch a
million shows where they're going to
just give you the grind out what
happened today thing and I want to do
some of the philosophic under pendings
on what has to happen now but just
imagine what would you do so all of
these
these all of these
Progressive um tolerant
people who now seemingly are siding with
butchers what would what would you do
because they will behead you but again
they'll just behead you last so what has
Hamas done here let's let's get a little
more info because it's breaking right
now by the way there's thousands of
rockets raining all over Israel right
now including Jerusalem you would think
that maybe they'd leave Jerusalem alone
because you know I thought they're
supposed to like Jerusalem but no uh
here's some info from the Atlantic uh
more accounts are emerging of
kidnappings rapes and torture committed
by Hamas terrorists against Israeli
civilians so far at least 150 Israelis
most of the most of them apparently
civilians were kidnapped by Hamas gunmen
and stolen across Israel's border with
Gaza by the way we don't know how many
of those people are Americans but we
know at least several of them are among
the kidnapped are elderly women and
small children humans human rights
groups are tracking these kidnappings as
evidence of war crimes within hours of
the attacks on Saturday photos and
videos began to circulate showing the
mass murder of Israeli civilians
including people killed in their cars
and left dead on the ground in streets
at a bus stop as well as the kidnapping
of children young women and the elderly
two widely circulated videos have
sparked outrage because of the apparent
sexual assaults they depict The Times of
Israel reports one video shows a woman
who appears to have been beaten and who
seems to be bleeding in her shorts being
forced out of a Jeep in Gaza the other
video shows a woman later identified by
her family as 22-year-old shaie Luke uh
stripped out to her underwear and lying
face down in a truck her legs Twisted at
unnatural angles Hamas gunman sit on her
body and bystanders spit on it according
to the Washington Post Luke was
kidnapped at a music festival where
Hamas killed at least 260 people tablet
magazine reports that the many that many
of the women executed at the festival
were raped next to their friends bodies
dead bodies before being killed some of
those who survived were kidnapped and
seen paraded through the city streets in
Gaza by their captors blood gushing from
between their legs tablet recorded
reported all right
so so how do I do this show properly
like how how do we how do we that's not
how I do show properly how do we all do
this nobody wants to see this stuff
nobody wants to hear about this stuff if
we do not witness it now as it is
unfolding right this second then it will
happen again and I would venture to say
it might happen to you or someone you
know because this is it a civilizational
war barbarism vers
civility right it's here it is a
Timeless war that has always gone on
Good Guys bad guys like it's not it's
not just I can see that there's this
sort of amoral people out there you know
I've been very disappointed listening to
a lot of libertarian commenters who I
mostly like when it comes to like
property rights B well not on borders
but property rights and just sort of
live Live and Let Live attitude they
can't take a moral position on anything
and guess what the people who can't take
a moral position on anything just like
the they thems they're going to behead
you too right they will come for you too
that's how it works you think at the end
after they've wiped out all the Jews and
they took out all the rest of the
liberal Elite and everyone else you
think they're going to oh boy those you
know those Libertarians they just want
to smoke pot would you just let them
smoke their pot no that's not how it
works uh so now to like just beyond
unspeakable Beyond unspeakable this is
from about an hour ago on Fox News
um operation continues we're also
getting word that alarms are going off
in Tel Aviv uh new rocket fire uh there
also uh getting some horrific uh images
uh coming from Israeli television a
reporter in the kabot uh kafer AAR uh
said the commander the Israeli commander
who liberated it from Hamas says they
found the bodies of 40 babies um and
some of them with their heads uh cut off
and that's horrible to even say uh but
this reporter is on the ground talking
to the commander of this kabut um and
there is video of this this interview
the atrocities the uh specific nature of
what we're seeing out of this is
actually hard to even calculate uh we're
joined 40 babies some of them
beheaded um as we were playing that
Phoenix just gave me a note uh an update
from the Israel war room there are now
photos emerging of Jewish children
burned alive by Hamas we're not going to
show them to you here but I I just saw
them just literally on the Fly just this
second 40
babies if you cannot F if you cannot
figure out what side you are on you you
are so morally confused or broken and
and in some ways I sympathize with you
to to an extent you have been broken by
A system that was designed to break you
years of coid horrible education media
that was awful people that lied to you
about everything and now you have no
idea where you are wandering the
desert and you better figure out what is
what is right and wrong so I think the
challenge for me and the challenge for
for everyone that is decent right now is
how do we talk about these things and
not burn ourselves out overnight I have
no doubt that some of you are watching
this right now like man this s like we
all know this
sucks understatement of the century um
and nobody wants to see these things
nobody wants to see the things that I've
seen that you've seen well Hamas wants
to see them and I think AOC honestly
wants to see them and I think R Talib
wants to see them but I'm showing them
to you so they don't leave your mind so
you know you know 80 years ago they said
never again well again here we are again
here we are again and remember they had
pgrs and they had all sorts of stuff
killing Jews all over the place before
Israel so this has nothing to do with
Israel this is an ongoing religious War
that's what it is so now as uh we talk
about some of the people that are
defending these monsters and some of the
people uh that are excusing it and
everything else this one this one hits
it's it's going to hit I'm just warning
you uh is an Israeli child reacting to
Hamas executing her sister in front of
her and her
[Applause]
siblings
[Music]
relax
no is my sister
died
in case you're unclear what's going on
there that barbaric Savage who
who will burn in hell one way or another
uh that that's screaming in the
background they're talking to their
captor there who just killed their
sister that so that's why they were
speaking some English there because
obviously he speaks Arabic they speak
Hebrew um Hamas has also released a uh a
statement that they will now start
executing Israeli civilians and by the
way they have American civilians um on
live television and posted on social
media for every air strike that uh that
Israel responds with to put an end to
this from this moment on
we announce that any targeting of
innocent civilians without warning will
be met regretfully to say by
executing one of the hostages in our
custody and we will be forced to
broadcast this
execution regretfully they'll be forced
to do that um and he also says if
they're killed without warning Israel
still even now is warning people as
they're leveling Gaza get out of the
house get out of the apartment building
go you can't St here they're they're
dropping leaflets with maps telling
people where to go no other country on
Earth would ever do that after this
America would have nuked Gaza already
right
like so that's what they're doing it's
strange that as what we pointed out
yesterday uh that Egypt oh by the way
you know can we grab that map again that
we showed yesterday not the one with the
little with the colors the the second
map that we grabbed yesterday if we were
able to grab that that would be good uh
I mentioned to you yesterday that maybe
Egypt could open their border of course
they won't um but Egypt officially
announced today they will not open their
border so they will not let any of their
Palestinian Brothers right and of course
uh Gaza was part of Egypt before 1967
because again there never was a
Palestinian State tell me who the Prime
Minister was or who the president was
just doesn't exist uh but uh we'll get
that map in just a little bit um but you
understand one of the things that I talk
about what's one of the phrases I use
here all the time politics is Downstream
from culture right that's a great quote
by Andrew Breitbart so how did we lose
all of this how did we lose all of this
so that we have in essence Hamas members
in Congress so we have people in the
streets of New York City cheering on and
not just New York City we'll get to some
of that in just a second cheering on the
heading of children how did we get there
and a media that lies to us and
everything we'll get to that in a second
I want to show you this map for a second
we pulled this one up yesterday uh so
you're seeing Israel again tiny tiny
country the size of New Jersey there the
giant um sort of uh thing with the edge
there between Israel and Egypt uh which
is hitting the Red Sea if you look at
the sort of north of the Red Sea that's
Sinai okay that's between Israel and
Egypt Israel had Sinai for a while after
one of the wars and gave it back to
Egypt for peace and there's basically
been peace between Egypt and Israel ever
since because you get peace through
strength um The Border as you can see
Gaza which is on the edge of Israel
there shares a border with Egypt with
Sinai they could put all the people
there basically no one lives in Sinai
it's a massive piece of land bigger than
is they put everyone there tomorrow stop
all of this immediately they will not
and you need to understand that they
there is no chance in high hell that
they will uh but let's continue because
one of the bigger problems when I talk
about how politics is Downstream from
culture is that we live in a time where
the mainstream media has lied to us
about almost everything they have lied
to us about this conflict and a fake
occupation and all of these things
forever they have lied like everything
related to Trump related to coid very
fine people on both sides um the list
goes on and on right like they have lied
to us about everything and the problem
is when you lie about everything then
people do not know what is true so even
now even now as all of this is happening
and these videos are everywhere fared
Zakaria on CNN brought on Mustafa barudi
who's a Palestinian I think he's in the
cabinet uh and listen to what he says
and and F just lets him say it I mean
absolute AB je horse go the what
Hamas is doing is they are
targeting Israeli
civilians women children grandmothers
they are not uh is that is that is that
not a classic Terror isn't that classic
terrorism they're not fighting the
Israeli government they're fighting
Ordinary
People that's one way of putting it but
it's not true I think Hamas mainly
attacked military establishments many
military installations and most of the
people they they have arrested and taken
as pres war war prisoners are military
people I do not accept attacking any
civilian uh uh I do not accept that
Israelis attack our civilians but look
at what Israeli planes are doing now in
Gaza they they are bombarding houses
they're bringing down to earth and
you've SE you've shown that on your uh
on your screen look I get that that
guy's just a piece of you know
propagandist liar right like that's what
he's there for he's doing his job I
actually have a bigger problem with
fared Zario who puts these people on and
fed's been doing this for years
with these people putting on these
apologists to lie they are telling you
don't see what you see with your own
eyes it doesn't even matter what fared
said after that that you let this person
on that guy should never be on CNN and
fared should be fired but I get it I get
it like that's not going to happen this
is how the machine operates um but they
are no they're they're civilians they're
yeah yeah the 250 kids who were at the
Rave that you just mauled down the 40
kids that were beheaded babies not not
not kids toddlers babies
babies
um as if that's not bad enough and it's
bad like the mainstream media is just is
just completely it has completely
collapsed at every level MSNBC is the
worst CNN by you know what I'm going to
give somebody credit for a moment um
Jake Tapper on CNN uh uh is doing a
decent job Jake I believe he's a
Democrat activist I think he's confused
a lot of the issues over the years I I
you know I've made a lot of fun of him
on a bunch of these things I think he's
one of the people that in some ways sort
helped Usher all of this nonsense in by
treating the Democrats and Republicans
so differently but he has actually been
uh pretty good and he is describing them
as Hamas terrorists which I'm sure CNN
is not thrilled with anyway over on
MSNBC who are they uh basically saying
they'll get a big win out of this yeah
it's Netanyahu I mean it's just clown
show go this is the kind of thing
that unites a country uh when when you
send 2200 Rockets overnight into Israel
does the do the internal protests in
Israel fall away as Israelis uh rally
around Benjamin Netanyahu who will
clearly come down on on uh on Hamas in
Gaza with an iron fist yeah and I was
just in Israel covering those protests
against that judicial effort by
Netanyahu I couldn't think of a better
gift for Benjamin Netanyahu right now
than this kind of incursion he can now
position himself as he has repeatedly
throughout his very long tenure running
Israel he can now say I am the sole
protector of this nation if you go
against me look at what you're up
against and that is what we're seeing
right now Matt Bradley foreign
correspondent for the televised mental
institution on his mbbc you are an
absolute clown if you think for one
moment that that Netanyahu who has spent
his life defending his people who built
Israel into an unbelievably strong state
with no natural resources and turned it
into ACH technological Powerhouse that
he's the winner of this thing first off
he's going to obviously have to step
down at the end of this thing they're
going to have their mil military
operation I hate to tell you AOC but
Israel is going to survive they're going
to have their military operation and he
will step down most likely in shame I
think he will probably have it's not
even worth talking about this yet but I
think he will most likely he he knows
what's right for the country and he
loves the country and I think he will he
the intelligence failures that led to
this those are on his watch he will he
will fix the situation and step down but
that they want to pin this yes it's such
a win politically for him it's the most
cynical just
absolute awful dishonest take on
anything but speaking of awful dishonest
takes medy Hassan uh who previously has
called uh gays and Jews pigs and you
know cattle and a whole bunch of other
stuff he's horrible on MSNBC here's what
he writes and he tries to sound pretty
bright when he's saying it strategically
killing civilians in Gaza who aren't
Hamas won't hurt Hamas it'll help them
in the long run morally killing
civilians in Gaza as part of an over
show of force isn't moral it's immoral
uh no if um let's say turkey attacked
Greece Greece would have every right to
do whatever the hell it wanted to Turkey
if Guatemala attacked Mexico Mexico
could do whatever it wanted to Guatemala
you don't you don't attack back
proportionately all these people it's
disproportionate okay yes we should
round up can we get me 1300 uh women and
children from Palestinians uh could you
guys rape could you guys rape about a
thousand of those women and behead some
of the kids how many do we work out the
numbers guys Jews were pretty good with
numbers usually we got an accountant
here oh okay so we raped exactly the
amount of people so it's
proportionate no it is absolutely moral
to to defend your people as you see fit
the Palestinians made their choice they
they elected
Hamas all of these years of all of the
entire Western Elite being sympathetic
to these people giving them billions of
dollarars and what did do with it they
didn't buy shelters and iron domes as uh
as Hamas caucus member ilhan Omar wanted
they built an army they built an army
that's what they built in uh in Gaza and
you can see it right now right it's an
open air prison they're all starving
they all look pretty decent and wellfed
and they have an army everything that
these people have offered you is
and speaking of one
more from MSNBC uh here are as an MSNBC
analyst explaining that that here's how
you negotiate with terrorists you
basically give them what they want if
you're thinking that far ahead and I
think that's smart getting to a
Palestinian state it becomes more
difficult uh because of all the Israeli
settlements in the West Bank the the
supported by the government settlements
in the West Bank even though the
International Community condemns them H
how do you do that does this make Israel
rethink that or do they just double
down well I was hoping Israel was
rethinking that um the the Coalition of
of prime minister nety
which which is substantially to the
right of him uh includes people who were
very much for neutering the role of the
Israeli Supreme Court and for expanding
settlements into area sea and parts of
the West Bank which would make it
impossible for there to be a contiguous
Palestinian State uh and rolling that
back yes would would be something to
consider not today but uh sadly uh soon
if we can get to some form of of uh of
of cessation of the hostilities uh and
return of the
hostages oh right lady in America who
spent most of her day with her hairspray
who I think was on season 4 episode
three of The Golden Girls if they would
just if they would just do what you want
we'd get peace hamas's Charter calls for
the extermination of Israel all of the
dead Jews all of them right me too
everybody gone but we just by the way
Netanyahu has not expanded Israel even
one square mile in his time in office
okay they've built apartments in places
that Jews have lived for thousands of
years again Jesus of Nazareth where do
you think Nazareth is Judea and Samaria
now known as the West Bank right it's
where the story of Hanukkah every Jew
for the every Jew that you know you're
watching this you've met a Jew you met a
Jew right uh they celebrate Hanukah
right and it's the story of Saving uh an
an
incredible unbelievable assault by the
Greeks and in the Judean Hills which
they now call the West Bank because
everything they do to to say the West
Bank it's the West Bank of the Jordan
River but before 1967 it was always
known as the Judean Hills you're not
going to believe who lived in Judea it's
nuts right um but yes if we could if
just guys Kamas could you if okay you
raped all the people you did everything
you wanted to do how about if we um
remove all of our citizens there so
there's no Jews there so that'll be kind
of like what Hitler wanted to then you
guys will call it off you promise not to
rape anybody else clown show
uh here's former State Department
official Aaron David Miller he has been
wrong about almost everything for 30
years related to all of this and he's
very concerned that Israel might might
hurt some people now that you know the
dead babies and everything what is their
response going to be the Prime Minister
has declared war declared war on Hamas
when you declare a war you aim for
victory but I ask myself the basic
question exactly what did the Israelis
hope to achieve reoccupation of the Gaza
Strip a major ground incurs I to destroy
hamas's military leadership Muhammad
Dave who's already been a a legitimate
Target of of the Israelis has been very
vocal the Israelis may want to eliminate
hamas's leadership but where does this
go wolf that's the real problem where's
the strategy to ensure that this is not
a a brutal and horrific uh rinse wash
and repeat cycle oh right we got another
college professor on who's accomplished
nothing in his life and does have to
live with the rape of his wife and
Rockets raining down on his head guys
could you just ease up don't Oh no
you're going to blow up those buildings
ah how many text messages did you send
before you blew up the building how many
times did you tell them hey we want
nothing to do with you but if you kill
our women we're going to have to do
something about it you clown clown show
that's what these people are but now I
want to expand this to something else
because what I started doing at the Top
If You Remember seven days ago at the
top of the show uh is that I was
connecting this to the radicalism of the
Democrat Party and the radicalism of the
Democrat Party I would say is also
connected to hyp secularism these people
believe in nothing but the government
they believe that up and down is left
and right they don't believe in biology
and everything so what we have now in a
weird way is why I've described
everything happening I always say that
the the problems are not political
they're spiritual in a sense I'm not
saying you have to be a devout religious
whatever catholic christian Jew or
anything else but there is like there is
like an inherent problem when we are all
disconnected from truth so I would say
politics is not only Downstream of
culture but it's also Downstream of
theology if we don't know what we are
and who we are and why America is good
and why Western theology means anything
and why between Jerusalem and Athens you
could come up with this nugget of
something so freaking amazing that we've
had for a couple hundred years on Earth
which is not the default position of
people to live in free societies if you
don't know why any of that happened well
then congratulations you'll give it back
to the Savages and by the way the
Savages are now they're showing
themselves uh here is a woman there were
many protests Pro Hamas protests in New
York City and they're showing Nazi flags
and you know great great group of people
and they're in New York City and who
knows how many of them we just L into
the country uh here's a woman uh she's
not really into America it doesn't seem
like I spoke to a guy before this and he
said America First you weren't happy
with that why Israel would not exist
without America so no America First for
you no are you an American yes and you
don't want to put America First no
now America First for her uh the idea
that Israel would not exist without
America is also not true when the
British Empire ended in 1948 they left
the British left and then there was just
land there right there was just land
they had offered we went through this
yesterday they had offered to divy it up
hey you guys you Arabs there were no
Palestinians at the time it was not a
people that existed you Arabs will get
some there was a the 1947 un partition
plan you Arabs will get some you Jews
will get some Israel would have been
much smaller than it is today but the
Jews said okay we we'll take it we'll
take it it would be nice you know we
just got Holocaust it it would be pretty
nice to have a little something that we
could call ours and not be hunted and
hounded down as we have throughout our
history the Arabs had no launch a war
lost blah blah blah but the point is uh
they didn't get the state because
America America did recognize the state
shortly after har Truman did recognize
the state I think about a day after um
but the but the they got a state by
living on the land and create taking a
desert and turning it into a paradise
that is that is now unfortunately not
much of a paradise uh but these
protesters and they're they're telling
you who they are right like they're
telling you they're telling you we
sympathize with people who murder babies
and everything else and at what point I
don't know exactly what the point is now
and I think we're going to really have
to rethink this and I and I as a look I
was put on the map in large part as a as
a free speech Advocate right someone
that was fighting for free speech at
what point if all of your allegiances as
an American are to foreign terrorist
organizations and you excuse and
celebrate the murder of innocent people
all over the world at what point uh do
we have a problem on our hands here in
America here's a Palestinian
demonstration in New York City
[Applause]
yesterday they're really into Palestine
a country that never existed uh but
putting that aside for a second I think
the reason that they're into Palestine
is they think that they're the
indigenous people there right again the
Jews somehow thousands and thousands of
years story of Hanukkah Western temples
that existed for thousand years none
none of that matters they built a Mosk
on top of the temple which do you think
came first this is basic engineering
right um but they seem to think this is
about indigenous people do those strike
you as Native Americans were did any of
those people strike you as Native
Americans possibly I didn't see any TPS
or I didn't even see Elizabeth Warren in
that thing um so what right do you have
to be here
unless actually once you think you're
done with Israel you will turn that evil
onto America which is obviously
what they plan on doing here they are
outside in
Chicago by the BDS movement as it
grew and I have to tell you the truth
the racism of the
Zionist long live the inty father long
live the in from the river to the Sea
it's written in sort of like that German
font so you can sort of see um
they're calling the Israelis racist it's
just incredible there are there are
Muslim Arabs who sit on the Supreme
Court of uh of Israel there are in
Israel you can have any job any
profession anything you want to do as an
Arab if you go to Jordan or Lebanon
there are there are dozens of jobs
Google it that you cannot have as a
Palestinian
um it's just the it's well it's
extraordinary but it's just
obvious what can I tell you but here
they are in but it's but let's focus
guys because right this is just about
the Israelis it's about these mean Jews
who got a couple guns and were able to
defend themselves right and Jews are
supposed to live on their knees they
they're a minority minorities are
supposed to be pathetic and always
holding to the power Jews don't do that
it doesn't fit the intersectional
calculator but really what this is is
about Israelis right it's not it's not
about Jews right we don't hate all the
Jews cued the Sydney Opera House in
Australia yesterday and this chant might
disturb
you
fuuuuuu
there's an invasion happening but it
ain't Israel invading Palestine an
imaginary place right uh there's an
invasion happening but it's happening in
Sydney Australia and it's happening in
London and it's happening in Chicago and
New York City again when you if let's
let's say you're watching this and I
think it's a fair estimation to be just
like as an American to be like you know
what I don't want anything to do with
any of this stuff and and hopefully you
would take a moral position right um but
the point is if you think that this has
nothing to do with you it does because
these people are now in our countries
there what do you think those people
want a a free Australia you think they
watch Crocodile Dundee on the weekends
drink of fosters no like it's just so
obvious it's ridiculous here's
[Music]
London
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Brock just made a great point it's
like you know Australia had some of the
most Draconian lockdowns ever I know
that was London what we just showed you
there but the previous one obviously was
Sydney Australia which by the way that
that was just deeply depress I mean it's
deeply depressing at sort of just like
an existential level and human hatri and
how broken some people's brains and
hearts can be the last stop that Jordan
and I did on the international portion
of the tour was at the Sydney Opera
house it was one it was truly one of the
best professional days of my life the
most beautiful theater we had ever been
in I didn't even realize it was a a
theater in the round it was an
absolutely gorgeous day it was the only
MAA show we did the entire time I walked
out on that Boardwalk that they're now
killing you know calling for gas the
Jews and Jordan and I walked outside and
and there were throngs of people that
wanted to say hi to him and it was just
an absolutely just wonderful wonderful
day now it's where they screaming G Jews
London has a problem on its hands
Britain has a problem on its hands again
this has nothing to do with Jews you
take out all the Jews guess what they're
still coming for you they're still
coming for the people of London the good
Brits so the Western countries are going
to have to decide what are you doing
what are you doing right now you guys we
know already I mean we've seen over the
last 10 years you let all these people
in you didn't assimilate them in America
we've done a much better job and by the
way I am in no ways bigoted towards Arab
people or Muslims or anything else I'm
bigoted towards those people those
people who Express those views that are
so antithetical to everything we know to
be uh congr with a free Society those
are the people that I'm bigoted against
and I am bigoted against them and you
should be too you should discriminate
against them because we all discriminate
right you don't have everyone as a
friend you discriminate and pick your
friends I don't like those guys very
enough very much anyway I tweeted out
I've already repeated it but here we go
how long till the Hamas swing of London
goes after the britz so just note that
can we put a little pin in that one day
because when it when it comes there uh
we should have known we should have
known uh I want to now show you a video
because I want to get to the to the
clarity part of this because I promise
you for as long as um all of this goes
on and I do want to say I will try to
watch my language a little bit more I
got to get these F bombs out of my
system but I I know like I I have to do
what is natural to me U but I know also
some of you do watch the show with kids
or or whatever it might be so I'll try
to be somewhat aware of that um but I
want to get to some solution part
portion of it and I will always try to
do that when I wrap up these shows
because the solution has been in front
of us and the solution has been
something that has been obvious to human
Civilizations for all the time you you
defend your people you live in a place
with people that are like-minded you you
have a culture and you defend it and you
decide these are our Traditions these
are our Foods these are our this is our
music these are our values and you say
this is ours you can do what you want
over there and by the way that's exactly
what Israel did with Gaza we want
nothing to do with you anymore you
didn't want one Jew we literally pulled
them out of synagogues you burn them
down we want nothing to do with you and
they were paid back with the rape and
murder of their
children but every society every society
that has ever existed it existed because
it defended its culture and its people
so now we found this video it's an old
one but this is from old it's from 2018
this is British Channel 4 host Kathy
Newman and some of you may remember
Kathy Newman she was the one that sort
of put Jordan Peterson on the map when
she asked him a series of some of the
dumbest questions ever and he just
annihilated her here she is in
2018 talking to a a Polish Member of
Parliament his name is Dominic tar sinki
I hope I I said that right and she asks
him how many refugees has Poland taken
in because you may remember this is
during the Syria War 5 years ago
refugees rampaging through Europe taking
over Germany uh going through France
right like destroying Paris all this
stuff and Europe has that on their hands
now and they they fully regret it here
she is trying to guilt this member of
Polish par Parliament into how many
he'll take watch this how many refugees
has Poland
taken zero and you're proud of of that
if you are asking me if you're if you
are asking me about Muslim uh Muslims
illegal immigration none not even one
will come to Poland not even one if it's
illegal we we took over 2 million
ukrainians who are working who are
peaceful in Poland we will not receive
even one Muslim because this is what we
promised but I ask not about illegal
immigrants I asked about refugees and
jeanclaude junker the commission
President says that you're race
you sound proud of the fact that you
haven't taken any
refugees of course because this is what
our people expecting from our government
that's number one this is why our
government was elected that this is why
Poland is so safe this is the the the
reason why we had not even uh one
terrorist attack look at the streets in
Poland and we can be called populists
nationalists racists I don't care I care
about my family and about my country I
want to what's the national drink of
Poland I want to have a drink with that
guy whatever it is I want the I will buy
the most expensive bottle of whatever
the national drink of Poland is you know
you can make all the jokes you want
about Poland and Polish people but
godamn they got it right right it's
vodka the I guess polish vodka I guess
that does make you always think of it as
Russian but yeah okay close enough um
he's he's right and the way she tries to
guilt him in it and you won't let in one
and I you know one day one day when they
take over Britain and then they behead
Kathy Newman there's going to be a guy
holding Kathy Newman's head and he's
going to have the finger one up because
that's their sign like we we did it you
didn't let one in someone will put
they'll make a meme of it that that's
where this is all heading these guilty
pathetic liberals in Western societies
who would fall on the sword and then
there wouldn't it be something the whole
world ends but Poland exist wouldn't
that be the ultimate choke it would be
the ultimate irony ha you asked how many
of us it took to screw in a light bulb
and here we
are does all this sound familiar the
guilting of people who do the right
thing the attacks and the lies you don't
we and he I love it he says we don't
care you call us racist we don't we
don't give a okay we don't care you
know who else say they called racist for
years and years and years and they said
he was a Nazi but it turns out they were
the Nazis yeah Donald Trump here he is
in 2015 when he was talking about
building a wall and build and having a
border you either have a nation or don't
now look he didn't build the wall he
didn't but we stopped a lot of illegal
immigration right we absolutely did and
I do believe that whether it's him or
disantis or anyone else that Republicans
will at least fix this to some extent
but just remember the backlash he faced
back in
2015 Trump is enraging many people with
his remarks about Mexican immigrants
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists and some I assume
are good people how can you succeed when
you say things like that well you can't
again Gail if the question is how can
you become president you can't by saying
things like that on Fox and Friends
today Trump spoke about the controversy
are you concerned about alienating the
Hispanic vote by saying that Mexico is
not our friend and we're building a wall
if it's good for me or bad for me I
don't think of that I think of saying
the right thing and people have to be
alerted to the fact that we are getting
some really bad characters coming into
this country by the way that that's the
Donald Trump that I actually came to
love and was right about a lot of things
and L voted for and everything else
that's and I and actually you know one
of the bizarre offshoot sort of
refreshing things over the last couple
days is how how Trump has said the right
thing Dan Santa say like we don't even
have to do any of that stuff for a while
I think we can put that aside like there
is a side politically that actually
makes sense right now and and I want to
give credit where credit is due with
Trump I mean there's so just the way
they frame everything these liberal
elitists and that weird John Hilman
remember that guy John hman we showed
you there from the CBS clip he was the
guy that Russell brand absolutely
destroyed and what did he say how when
she what's her name Gail King who's I
think Oprah's lesbian lover when she was
like
uh when she was like um and how can you
do this how can you say those mean
things well you can't if you want to
become president and he became president
it's like and then John Hollman blocked
me on Twitter by the way so you guys can
send him this clip if you
want so what is the alternative what was
the alternative to Trump then well there
was this woman Hillary Clinton remember
her uh so we could have not done some of
the things that Trump did right because
even by by coming across as a racist
even if you're not a racist sometimes
you scare some of the people right like
you make it seem like oh they shouldn't
come to the Border because that guy's
really racist we shouldn't come then you
get some old buffoon in like Joe Biden
and then they come either way right even
though we tell them that the borders we
do in fact tell them that the border is
open uh so this we're almost at the end
guys I promise and I think this is
officially our longest show ever um
Hillary
Clinton uh was making the rounds again
and I think it's partly because I don't
think it's completely out of the realm
of possibility that they will run her
again when they get rid of Biden I think
most likely it's Gavin and they got to
figure out the Cala Harris thing but
she's been making the rounds on the
media again and if you want to see the
authoritarian Tendencies of these people
I can have whatever frustrations I want
with Donald Trump but do you know that I
never go after his supporters I never do
I I I was one of them I might be one of
them again and and these were good
decent Americans who just had who were
out of the overden window of of what you
authoritarian freaks allowed but they
were deplorables they always go after
these people that what they've done to
the people of January 6 you guys get all
this stuff anyway she's back in the
media making the rounds again uh and
here she's officially calling for uh
Cult deprogramming of citizens she
doesn't like very strong partisans in
both parties in the past uh and we had
very bitter battles over all kinds of
things gun control and climate change
and the economy and taxes but there
wasn't this little tale of extremism
waving you know wagging the dog of the
uh Republican party as it is today and
sadly so many of those extremists those
Mega extremists um take their marching
orders from Donald Trump who has no
credibility left by any measure he's
only in it for himself he's now
defending himself in civil actions and
criminal actions and when do they break
with him you know because at some point
you know maybe there needs to be a
formal deprogramming of the cult members
but something needs to happen what an
insane statement now again you know
where I started the show about the
radicalism of the Democrat Party that
caused a guy like RFK Jr a true liberal
who I have some political different
disagreements with to leave the party
then I think we Illustrated how the
radicals have taken over and how the bad
ideas have now burst forth into various
socities all over quite literally all
over the globe and then you have her
Hillary Clinton who lost to Trump called
him an illegitimate president back in
the days when you could question
election results and then she says that
the there's this uh what does she say
there's this radical version of the
Republicans that Wag the little tale of
extremism in the Republican Party think
which is more radical is it the Maga
people that want a border and want Law
and Order and to defend the Constitution
and all those things and by the way have
peace in the Middle East which he did
and a whole bunch of stuff like that or
would you say that it's the Hamas caucus
and the wers who are wagging the little
tale of extremism of the Democrats that
lead them to exactly where we are at
right now which not only leads them to
bad policies and everything else but
then leads to a moment where Hillary
Clinton is up there calling for some
sort of formal I mean she went out of
her way some sort of formal
deprogramming she didn't say you know we
should figure out a way to talk to these
people and every some sort of formal
deprogramming struggle sessions Hill you
know sure you've had a couple of those
with Bill after he raped some chicks
like you guys sold your soul to the
devil enjoy um okay we're almost there
guys um so what what do you do
well what do we all do within the
American version of this with our
political system well I can link that
very quickly back to RFK at the top he
woke up because of the Border he was
struggling with the woke stuff he he
believes in Liberal values whether you
agree with him on those principles or
not and and he's waking up right now and
what have I been saying for years now Ed
noi the sliver of people who can still
wake up in America are the disaffected
libs I'm seeing it right now I'm seeing
a lot of of even Lefty
Jews suddenly being like okay okay we
tried to be nice to everybody we thought
being nice and being open was good but
uh you know we've had it we've just
about had it we let them into the bagel
shop and they took all the bagels it's
time to figure this new thing out okay
uh so what do you do you encourage
people to wake up and Blaze a new Trail
and that's exactly what RFK is doing
right now as I've surrendered my
attachment taking sides over the past
six months I've been able to listen with
new ears to people with whom I disagree
and to see
solutions that would otherwise have been
invisible I'll give you an example six
months ago I thought that an open border
was a humanitarian policy and that
sealing the if you were for sealing the
Border it meant that you were probably a
xenophobe and maybe a
racist I was wrong how did I learn I was
wrong it wasn't just that I
listened it it wasn't just that I
listened to the other
side it was when I actually visited the
border and listened to people who
weren't on either side My Views change
and that's why I'm here today I'm here
to declare myself an independent
candidate
he listened to people and then his views
changed he used to think six months ago
if you wanted a closed border you were
xenophobic racist right that's what he
thought six months ago and he has woken
up and the people that are applauding
him there you may disagree with him on
abortion and affirmative action and a
bunch of other stuff as I do but they're
on their path to waking up and because I
believe that the truth cannot be stopped
I'll take some people waking up I think
it's pretty good you get some of that in
The Ether you never know what's going to
happen it starts spreading some good
things start happening and and to give
this guy some real credit beyond all of
that I am doing an event with him in
belir on October 26th he chose me to do
the event with him and he knows I'm not
supporting him as the presidential
candidate right I'll support him as far
as I
can but like think about that think how
profoundly different that is than
everything else we we've come to know
related to politics and think how
actually truly liberal that is it's not
liberal so you're open-minded till your
head till your brains fall out of your
head it's liberal so that you say oh
reality exist and we got to figure out
how to free people within reality not
upend the world in in the Quest for
world domination or whatever these
freaks are doing so that's our program
for today I hope you enjoyed it I'm Dave
Ruben this is the Ruben report we've got
a full post game show for those of you
who want to watch uh and join us and ask
some questions and comments and and
really that's where I get to you know
connect with you guys in a in a just
different way than this Ruben report.
locals.com I leave you with a Israel
Palestine I you know I hate people keep
saying Palestine and even for our
Palestine never existed the British
Mandate of Palestine okay we've been
through all of that U but I have to even
stop doing because the default position
is somehow this is Israel versus
Palestine no that would be like saying
it's Israel vers Israel right it's not
because Palestine was the place of the
Jews but all right fine anyway we leave
you wi Conor's like wrap it up dude I
got to pee leave South Park just enjoy
and I'll see everybody at on the local
chat in a second mind well now you're
going to get it that's
right you and me right now we're having
it out let's go come on come
[Music]
on